[Aplausos]
alguna vez han dejado hacer algo
simplemente porque piensan que es
irrelevante
alguien
a los que dicen que no quiero hacerles
una pregunta nunca ha dejado un plato
sin lavar una chaqueta sin colgar o en
el piso y llega el fin de la semana y
nos preguntamos cómo carajos llegamos a
ese punto que tenemos un desorden que no
podemos con él
así como en este aspecto hay muchas
cosas en nuestro día a día los cuales
dejamos de hacer porque parecen
irrelevantes en el momento y solamente
cuando estamos en una situación
altamente incómoda nos damos cuenta de
esto y esto no sólo aplica para aquellas
cosas que están en nuestro día a día
sino también para nosotros como sociedad
y uno de los grandes problemas que
genera esto que son los plásticos por
ejemplo y es que nosotros no alcanzamos
a entender como tal el origen y el
problema que son los plásticos
yo quiero que alguien me diga de los que
están presentes saben cómo se originaron
nada bueno
en 1860 una empresa necesitaba encontrar
un sustituto para el material con el
cual hacían las bolas de billar el cual
era el marfil pues la población de
elefantes estaba disminuyendo
significativamente la curiosamente la
persona que encontró la forma de lograr
los plásticos no ganó pero si encuentra
una manera para poder hablar un producto
barato ligero y sobre todo muy
resistente y son estas ventajas las
cuales a la larga se convirtieron
nuestro problema puesto que vivimos en
una sociedad donde la disponibilidad de
las cosas inmediatamente y el valor que
le damos en el tiempo a las cosas hacen
que esto sea lo que más me ha hecho que
se expanda el uso de los plásticos en
los productos pues si vemos
absolutamente todos los días utilizamos
cosas que están hechas de plástico
nuestro cepillo de dientes porque es
barato hacerlos así el jabón está empacó
en plástico la comida está empacada en
plástica y cosas así por el estilo
actualmente se estima que el día de hoy
se han producido 8 mil 300 millones de
toneladas de plásticos lo cual equivale
a 25 mil hay spire states en peso mil
millones de él
antes y lo suficiente para cubrir un
país entero como la argentina el cual es
el octavo más grande del mundo y es 25
veces colombia y esto no parece que vaya
a bajar al contrario va a seguir
incrementándose puesto que solamente el
9 por ciento del plástico a nivel
mundial se recicla y para que entiendan
un aspecto de lo resistente y bueno que
este material como tal si hace 400 años
más o menos cuando la gente no había
como tal demostrado que la tierra era
redonda alguien hubiera notado una
botella plástico está a día de hoy aún
existiría es por eso que junto a
aspectos como que cada año se agregan 10
millones de toneladas de plásticos a los
océanos si seguimos en estos aspectos
para 2050 va a haber más plásticos que
peces en el mar ahora bien esto es esto
es algo muy negativo lógicamente pero
esto no es para que nos sintamos mal ni
nada por el estilo sino para que
tratemos de encontrar la mejor solución
y es que los plásticos per se no son el
problema somos nosotros lo que los que
no hemos sabido darles el uso adecuado
porque como tal el plástico se puede
reciclar pero no entendemos bien cuáles
son sus implicaciones y cuáles son los
aspectos que tenemos que manejar en él y
dudo que alguno de los acá presentes
llegue y utilice por ejemplo cubiertos
utilizables consigo todo el tiempo o
algo por el estilo históricamente
se han encontrado tres maneras para
poder resolver los problemas la primera
es a través de los cambios culturales y
estos empiezan en un aspecto que tienen
algo que es malo y no podemos resolver
este aspecto y es que estos nos cuestan
como tal sacrificio un ejemplo que
nosotros tenemos digamos un día a día es
cuando todos decimos y alguna vez estoy
seguro que lo hemos hecho que vamos a
hacer una dieta o que va a empezar el
gimnasio no es que este es mi año y yo
quiero en estas vacaciones ir con el
cuerpazo y algo por el estilo y las
primeras dos semanas vamos con todas las
intenciones y todas las ganas creo que
la tercera semana le bajamos un poco la
goma y termina el mes mes y media y
nunca volvemos a acabamos de serlo
porque esto es algo incómodo y esto baja
como tal nuestra calidad de vida por así
decirlo entonces dejamos de hacerlo y
nos sostenible en el tiempo la segunda
son a través de las leyes las cuales
hagan que estos productos sean más
costosos y por ende la gente deje de
consumirlos como fue el caso de las
bolsas clásicas acá en colombia sin
embargo eso tiene dos problemas
uno que es difícil a veces que el
gobierno como tal es simplemente por
diferentes intereses y dos puede que
esto no sea muy eficiente porque la
gente puede pagar el impuesto y no sabe
realmente el impacto que tiene y es ante
esto que viene la tercera opción que es
la innovación y como hemos visto
históricamente a través de ésta se han
resuelto diferentes disyuntivas que han
atacado como tal a la humanidad y hemos
sabido resolverlas un ejemplo fue con la
creación de los ascensores con los
ascensores pudimos hacer que los hijos
fueran mucho más altos y con esto la
urbanización de las ciudades dejó de
expandirse hacia los lados usualmente
cuando hablamos de innovación creemos
que esto es a través de grandes
creaciones o cosas muy revolucionarias
per se que nunca nos dimos a imaginar
pero yo creo que esto no es cierto
para mí esto puede hacerse a través de
pequeños cambios los cuales varias veces
han sido capaces de generar revoluciones
que han generado un gran impacto y como
tal han tenido un gran desarrollo y creo
que esa es la mejor solución para varios
problemas que tenemos es ante esto
y mente lo siguiente
y ese se ha cubierto por ejemplo que
tiene una ventaja y es que se vive gran
energía de plástico en un mes
aproximadamente dependiendo de las
condiciones
más o menos no alrededor de ese tiempo y
tiene una característica que lo hace
único
y es que sabe delicias
muchas gracias
curiosamente esto a mí no se me ocurrió
ni por ninguna iluminación ni nada por
el estilo sino para algo que me pasó en
un día a día y me encontraba haciendo un
trabajo para un trabajo de la
universidad en una especialización y
tiene que inventarme algún producto que
fuera nuevo para colombia' del mundo y
mientras pensaba que carajos hacer
estaba comiendo una empanada
y yo soy algo torpe como pueden ver
y me comí la empanada con la mitad de la
servilleta
algo que la verdad me parece me pasa más
a menudo de lo que ustedes imaginan
no sé hacer
mientras pensaba en lo molesto que es
esto
se me ocurrió porque uno no puede
comerse la servilleta o el envoltorio
con que vienen los alimentos y como todo
buen colombiano mientras le echaba aquí
a mi pana
pensé por qué no hacer lo mismo con los
cubiertos que utilizamos
puede que muchos de ustedes piensen esto
que puede ayudar al medio ambiente como
tal según cálculos que he hecho ha
realizado una persona utiliza 600 gramos
en plásticos al año y eso parece algo
irrelevante algo que no tiene mucho
impacto porque es un poco más de una
libra pero es ahí donde todos nos
equivocamos en los años 80
una empresa de aviación
decidí hacer una estrategia para poder
ahorrar en sus costos de una manera en
la cual sus pasajeros no se dieran
cuenta fue imperceptible
no la típica y voy a mandar los
separados como una vez salió una
aerolínea sino algo realmente sutil y es
que en cada una de sus ensaladas y a
servir una aceituna - sólo ahora
imaginen que servía 10
ahora ellos sirven 9
y relevante bueno con ese pequeño cambio
hace 30 años esa empresa
40 mil dólares y otra compañía que
servía tajadas de limón en todas sus
bebidas decidió hacer lo siguiente y era
que en vez de sacar 10 tajadas por acá
limón y a sacar 16 terminaron ahorrando
500 mil dólares al final de ese año que
también fue en la época de los 80 puede
que ustedes piensen que esto sólo puede
ser aplicado como tal a grandes
compañías porque ellos tienen la
capacidad de hacer la dsca bilidad de
las cosas pero ahí es donde nos
equivocamos porque usualmente tenemos el
concepto que las cosas muy pequeñas no
como tal no tienen ninguna repercusión
pero nunca nos sentamos a pensar
en cuál va a ser el impacto que éstas
tengan cuando todo el mundo las actas
volviendo al ejemplo
de los cubiertos
yo quiero que me digan una cosa quiénes
de ustedes tienen por lo menos 100
personas en facebook
instagram snap chat en sus teléfonos en
contactos de whatsapp o lo que sea creo
que para no tenerlos literal no tendría
ninguna esas cuentas todo el mundo los
tiene hay gente que tiene miles literal
millones
obviamente nadie habla con toda esa
gente es imposible pero todos realmente
podemos impactar en por lo menos 10
personas y de las personas que estamos
acá 100 impactarán en 10 y las
convencieron por ejemplo en la
relevancia que tienen uso de los
plásticos y adoptar a temas como este
estaríamos al de una reunión 2.000
personas que estarían mejorando el
impacto como tal y la contaminación que
existe y eso sería más de media tonelada
que estamos citando en contaminación
inmediatamente si fuéramos 10.000 serían
6 toneladas si fuéramos 100 mil serían
60 toneladas y si fuéramos un millón que
solamente el 2% 2 de la población de
colombia serían 600 toneladas no es la
solución final
pero realmente es muy buen inicio para
atacar un problema tenemos el concepto
que usualmente para poder solucionar
algo la única manera es mediante grandes
creaciones revolucionarias cosas que
dios me esto aina como se le ocurrió a
alguien pero esto no es así si bien son
necesarias es a partir de los pequeños
cambios
las pequeñas soluciones en las cuales
podemos encontrar una forma de arreglar
los problemas mientras podemos llegar a
las soluciones definitivas esto en
espacio y mucho menos es sencillo y
tampoco va a ser la respuesta para todos
los problemas que tengamos
pero si de algo hay certeza
es que todas las acciones que tengamos
pueden ser positivas siempre y cuando
creamos que son relevantes y ante esto
quiero ser la siguiente pregunta cuál va
a ser su próxima pequeña acción gracias
[Aplausos]